[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a este programa
especial de cultura de france 24
dedicado a la noche de las ideas
hablamos de una cita cultural que
comparten cada año países de los cinco
continentes durante la misma noche unas
200 ciudades de 75 países especialistas
sociólogos docentes filósofos
personalidades públicas y de la sociedad
civil reflexionan y debaten sobre un
tema en particular se trata de un evento
que tiene el nombre original de la nuez
decide y que nació impulsado por el
instituto franceses de parís en el año
2016 y en esta sexta edición se lleva a
cabo bajo el eje del tema cercanos y
bajo una modalidad virtual con algunas
pocas ciudades con presentaciones in
situ
y para adentrarnos en la noche de las
ideas y conocerlas desde más cerca nos
acompañan miguel ramis ella es
embajadora de francia en colombia y
clarisse paolini jefa del servicio de
cooperación cultural de la embajada
francesa en colombia miguel ramis
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
este programa especial de france 24 algo
que ya estaba adelantando al inicio del
programa pero quien mejor que usted no
para contarnos que es la noche de las
ideas como nació esta iniciativa y cuál
es su finalidad además perdón pero
quiero hacer una aclaración muchas de
las imágenes que vimos y que veremos
durante este programa especial
pertenecen a ediciones anteriores que
por supuesto no estuvieron marcadas por
este particular contexto de pandemia
y muchas gracias por la invitación a la
noche de las ideas es una fiesta yo
diría que es una efervescencia y fue
creada en 2016 por de hecho el ex
ministro de asuntos exterior del hogar
fabius que era un ministro a quien le
gustaba mucho el juego de las ideas era
un ministro muy intelectual que le
gustaba bueno los conceptos nuevos la
magia de los jugó de cerebro y lanzó
esta idea de las noticias ideas para
crear un como éramos un evento en el
cual todo el mundo puede participar en
discusiones sobre temas relevantes
instituciones sociedad civil estudiantes
yo me acuerdo muy bien que por la
primera vez de 2017 sabía en la calle
del ministerio una cola enorme a las 7
de la noche para entrar al ministerio de
asuntos exteriores y yo creo que es un
gran éxito que lanzó este este ministro
de acercar a la gente durante una noche
para que se tome en cuenta la opinión de
todos
no es un ejercicio un ejercicio
exclusivo es un ejercicio en el cual se
escuche se escucha a ministros escritor
estudiantes médicos y yo creo que lo
importante es cruzar experiencia hacer
como una fertilización cruzada y
realmente una una fiesta de la cual
puedes salir muchas cosas nuevas
combinaciones de propuestas y yo creo
que es realmente muy interesante para
bueno el futuro de las nuevas
generaciones para el de baterías que es
tan importante en la tengo que hacer así
que este evento como se lo mencionó se
va a desarrollar en 75 países -francia
al organizar los cinco continentes y va
a ser va a traducirse por este es
antenas de eventos de todos tipos de
espectáculo vivo para intercambio
cultural pero con modalidades virtuales
que vamos a detallar un poco más tardes
a clarice starling jefa del servicio de
cooperación cultural también de la
embajada francesa en colombia quisiera
preguntarle a usted por qué se escogió
en esta oportunidad el concepto de la
temática de cercanía no se había pensado
en ella con anterioridad
no tiene que ver por supuesto con este
contexto de pandemia
sí muchas gracias pues claramente si el
contexto particular de este año influyó
mucho en la decisión de escoger este
esta temática porque de hecho la
temática cerca nos cuestiona mucho con
muchas cosas sobre la transformación de
nuestro modelo de sociedad modelo
económico puesto en cuestión a la
relación que tenemos con nuestro espacio
o con la solidaridad con lo digital
también y creo que más que nunca
acercarnos me invita a todo el público
a cuestionar nuestra relación con los
demás en todos los ámbitos precisamente
algo muy enriquecedor no de estos
diálogos que se abren en la noche de las
ideas tiene que ver con que cada ciudad
y sus representantes que participan
abordan el tema de la cercanía desde sus
propias perspectivas desde sus
experiencias sus realidades y hay uno de
los países que participa es argentina
lionel paradisi coloma es consejero
cultural y de cooperación de la embajada
de france
en argentina y en diálogo con france24
nos contaba la propuesta de esta nación
sudamericana para este año escuchemos
vamos a poner de relieve la solidaridad
entre los artistas de argentina y los
artistas de francia a lo largo de los
años 70 y 80 en este momento tan
particular por supuesto de la historia
de argentina se formó un proyecto
cultural llamado proyecto eye that
realmente de diálogo entre los artistas
mucha solidaridad entre los artistas de
francia y de argentina con movimientos y
eventos culturales en parís y tenemos
realmente lindos vídeos lindos
testimonios audiovisuales de este
momento de solidaridad y estamos
siguiendo con esta tarea realmente de
verdad de memoria de justicia entre
nuestros dos países es la agenda de
francia porque estamos liderando a nivel
mundial una alianza en cuanto a la a la
lucha contra las desapariciones forzadas
entonces es realmente como un puente una
cercanía entre el pasado y la actualidad
de nuestra acción diplomática conjunta y
también podemos dialogar con claudia
gerard posee ella es embajadora de
francia en argentina y hablamos acerca
de esta idea de cercanía tema central
del evento de este año y esto nos decía
es un año en el cual las cercanías se
han vuelto un deseo más bien que hay una
aspiración y algo que nos parecía ser
normal era algo que ya no le dábamos
tanta importancia se transformó en un
anhelo me parece hay muchas cosas detrás
del concepto de cercanía a ella lo que
se conoce lo que el espacio
el espacio en el sentido físico el
espacio and el sentido psicológico
y conectarse con con nosotros es una
cosa importante y como uno se conecta
ahora por supuesto el tema digital la
presencia la ausencia todos esos temas
me parece que se encuentran detrás del
título de la noche kate porque además en
la argentina son cuatro noches y uno de
los participantes más destacados de esta
sexta edición de la noche de las ideas
es el filósofo alemán hartmut rosa quien
estuvo desarrollando de esta manera la
idea de como la filosofía nos acerca
filosofía y filosofía existe para frenar
los movimientos habituales de nuestros
pensamientos la costumbre regular de las
reglas establecidas y estructuras
nuestro listado de cosas por hacer
la filosofía rompe con todo eso y abre
nuevos horizontes sociales
cuando aceptamos una nueva opinión o
perspectiva generalmente con otras
personas dejamos a las cosas ser y
nosotros nos convertimos en nosotros
mismos de una manera más activa esto
crea una nueva conexión entre las
personas mientras éstas se dan cuenta
que
detrás de esos roles que cada uno tiene
también son seres humanos ansiosos por
abrir puertas y conocer cosas nuevas y
las continuamos adentrándonos en la
noche de las ideas en este programa
especial de france en 24.100 ramis está
acompañándonos ella es embajadora de
francia en colombia michelle también se
lleva a cabo la noche de las ideas
andinas verdad cuenta y no de qué se
trata
la noche andina es es una iniciativa
dentro de la noche decías es una
iniciativa lanzada por seis países
bolivia perú ecuador venezuela colombia
y argentina en el marco de las 24 horas
de la noche de las tías es pues es un
programa regional de reflexión sobre
cuestiones que tenemos en común con
estos países como por ejemplo la
cuestión amazónica la preservación
de biodiversidad y yo creo que es un su
comunidad
[Música]
una parte de la funcionalidad pero
regionalizada
y este año vamos a compartir con estos
tipos países en temas de interés común
es un intercambio muy importante que
puede inspirar a crear innovaciones
en el campo por ejemplo del del ambiente
y yo creo que va a ser muy importante
este enfoque de 5 países de 6 países de
hecho de la región andina saludamos
nuevamente a clarice tolini jefa del
servicio de cooperación cultural de la
embajada francesa en colombia a clarice
cuáles fueron los principales retos para
hacer este evento bajo una modalidad de
virtual no opuso uno de sus quizás
costados más positivos es que puede
reunir a más personas verdad
sí absolutamente yo creo que uno de los
principales retos fue que en la noche de
las ideas suele haber muchas actividades
muy diferentes porque la idea es llevar
la cultura dentro de las bueno este año
dentro de las casas y normalmente a las
personas directamente y entonces
teníamos un reto muy grande de poder
proponer este año también actividades
muy diversas como no solo debate de
ideas pero también baile música o sea
muchos muchos tipos de actividades y yo
creo que lo hemos logrado bastante bien
aquí en colombia por suerte pudimos
organizar algunas actividades en
presenciar y tipos de actividades que
van más allá del debate de ideas por
ejemplo en cartagena en otras ciudades
habrá hablando de momentos de baile de
música etcétera yo creo que eso es muy
importante
al final bueno hemos podido hacer un
evento híbrido que eso es muy importante
y al final sí hemos logrado también
alcanzar a públicos muy diversos y muy
largo porque por supuesto lo virtual
permite llevar la cultura dentro de las
casas como lo decía antes y entonces
quizás y esperemos alcanzar a gente que
normalmente quizás no nos iría a debates
de ideas etcétera y además pudimos dar
la palabra a gente que normalmente no se
suelen escuchar mucho por ejemplo
grabamos unos vídeos de un chófer de
taxi en bogotá
una mujer trans en el barrio del bronx y
todos esos vídeos estarán publicadas en
el sitio web de las 24 horas de la noche
de la de las ideas precisamente para dar
espacio y para que gente que no pueden
que no suelen ser muy escuchadas puedan
ser más visibles durante esa noche
bueno agradecemos muchísimo a michel
ramis embajadora de francia en colombia
y también por supuesto a clarice paulini
jefa del servicio de cooperación
cultural de la embajada francesa en
colombia por haber participado de este
programa especial de france 24 en
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación hay mucha más
cultura en france 24 y en france 24
punto com
[Música]